here's dave vincent one of the great
stories this year for miami and the
transformation from strictly a point
guard to combo guard strews downhill got
men at the rim and packed by horford
brown on the break williams with the
layup
great rotation and blocked shot
on a strews drive
and it ignited them for another
transition bucket
[Applause]
vincent pulls the three got it
right and again when he gets to his
right hand and it's in transition not in
traffic really hard to go
butler on the two-man game in the slam
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
here's strews
butler
jimmy butler sees a
lane attacks
you can make the cases contact
[Music]
shot clock down to five for smart
back out to tatum
side step three tough shot and splash
down
[Music]
sparks inbound it's tatum spins
fires
butter
screws again
fires the three
and that might do it al horford with the
rebound throws it up in the air and the
boston celtics will go to the nba finals
[Applause]
they complete a wire to wire victory
on the floor together
they're smart again from deep
and green with a quick outlet to curry
play
three
just look at the confidence you've seen
this movie before his ability to come
down throw it and look away he's not
even going sometimes you sneak peek he's
getting back he's not even paying
attention that's beautiful
and steph with a little bit of pace into
the front court
behind the screen
steph curry the warriors for the first
time go small with one big on the floor
on looney
a bunch of shooters and scorers
williams looks at that three and he
laces it
hurry with a quick outlet to ludi great
catch
and a better block by brown he packed it
[Applause]
right in transition to brown with a head
of steam and says it with his chest at
the other end think about the effort
great pass from curry but brown doesn't
give up on the play says not on my watch
and on the other end because of his
ability to get up and run
the denver series former finals mvp
still a key part of this warriors lineup
curry behind the screen oh they lost him
again
jaylen brown who had a strong first half
smart
goes around the world oh a little bit of
sauce
mark is smart
and he's playing with a lot of
confidence
[Applause]
hands it off to curry
those around the world
oh so much
and the craftiness the size and strength
the ability to eliminate elite defenders
and then finishing in traffic and get
you big-time buckets one-on-one on
attack oh williams caught a body
underneath
and here comes boston
a 7-0 run to start the fourth and final
quarter
white
good close out by curry it didn't matter
derek white celtics with a chance to
take the lead
white on the drive
back to horford for the lead
boston up by old state hasn't scored in
the last four minutes here's tatum
working against wigan
back out to smart in rhythm for three
splash
what a flurry
by boston 21 of 41
from three-point territory
that is
incredibly insane
and inordinate
the celtics take game one